wir schauen neidisch auf andere länder
um uns herum die endlich öffnen und wir
bei bild wir sagen ist reicht gibt uns
unser normales leben zurück darüber
werde ich gleich mit gesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach sprechen und natürlich
darüber was beim impfen bei der
impfpflicht und bei dem chaos um srk
passiert ist
die omikron wandtext mehr fälle jeden
tag hock rekordwerte bei neuinfektionen
und sieben tage incidents die reaktion
bestürzend schockstarre angst schüler
fordern jetzt gar weg mit der
präsenzpflicht im unterricht die politik
in panik vor der riesenwelle zweig zweig
plus leere plätze in den stadien
theatern und konzertsälen
vorsicht und verbote ansagen und
auflagen schutzmasken und schnelltests
info kampagnen und jetzt auch noch
impfpflicht für alle mindestens bis
ostern also noch zehn wochen mehr als
zwei monate sollen schranken bleiben und
das obwohl sich intensivstationen lehren
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen das
ist vor ostern zu exit strategien
komplex bei der lag bei unseren nachbarn
dagegen freude feier freiheit
großbritannien katalonien dänemark bald
auch finnland die beschränkungen weg die
korona mutante auch dort quicklebendig
und auf wachstumskurs
trotzdem keine massen keine kontrollen
keine coroner regeln freedom day bei
unseren nachbarn wann bewegt sich was
bei uns warum impfpflicht wann fahren
wir nach plan und nicht mehr auf sicht
viele fragen ihre fragen die richtigen
fragen paul ronzheimer stellt sie jetzt
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach
[Musik]
und jetzt ist der
bundesgesundheitsminister hier im studio
schönen guten abend herr lauterbach
hallo herr lauterbach die diskussion
werden heftiger warum in deutschland
nichts passiert und auch wir hier bei
bild wir sagen es reicht uns macht
endlich aufgibt uns unser normales leben
zurück warum weigern sie sich das zu tun
ist zunächst einmal also ist das
vollkommen verständlich dass die bürger
jetzt endlich also in die normalität
zurück wollen das ist absolut
verständlich ist anlegen und dem so
widmen wir uns ja auch aber man muss
überlegen passt das jetzt also wir haben
ja jetzt in die mikrowelle hinein
reformen gemacht die gut geklappt haben
wir haben eine gute also sterblichkeit
im vergleich zu anderen ländern wir
haben also relativ
moderate fallzahlen im vergleich zu dem
was sonst gewesen wäre das heißt die
strategie die wir gefahren haben klappt
im großen und ganzen wir sind aber noch
nicht über den berg hinweg und wieso
sollten wir was derzeit gut klappt was
uns schon ein paar hundert menschenleben
oder mehr gerettet hat wieso sollten wir
das wenige also wochen bevor wir die
welle gebrochen haben viel zu früh lag
aber um gekommen ist wesentlich
ungefährlicher als man gesagt hat es
gibt weniger hospitalisierung weniger
tote dadurch gleichzeitig sehen wir beim
cupid index der uni oxford dass
deutschland weltweit die strengsten
maßnahmen hat ist das wirklich etwas
worauf ich stolz sein sollten die
fallzahlen sind nicht so hoch wie sonst
wären ohne die massnahmen und die
sterbezahlen sind auch nicht so hoch
wenn man jetzt zum beispiel also auf
deutschland übertragen würde die
sterbezahlen mit omikron was ja nicht so
schwer verläuft wie data warnt und so
alles gut aber wenn man das jetzt
vergleichen würde dann würde sagen ja
was wäre denn in deutschland wenn wir so
vorgehen würden wie in england zum
beispiel dann hätten wir pro tag über
den daumen gepeilt vielleicht 300 tote
am tag und wir haben aber deutlich
weniger waren vielleicht 60 bis 80 tote
und das ist der unterschied zwischen
einer seiner restriktiven politik und
anna so lax und wenn ich einen satz zu
sagen darf wir schützen wirklich mit den
maßnahmen dass die omikron welle die
älteren menschen und die besonders
gefährdeten in dem maße erreicht wie das
sonst der fall wäre damit retten wir
jeden tag leben sie sagen wir retten
jeden tag leben gleichzeitig gibt es
erhebliche folgeschäden psychische
schäden bei kindern und jugendlichen
viele menschen die angst vor der pleite
haben wir sehen das kinder- und
jugendpsychiatrie volllaufen dazu möchte
ich ihnen einmal zeigen was unsere
zuschauerinnen legte länger zu sagen hat
herr lauterbach jetzt stehe ich vor
ihnen und habe die frage wie geht es
ihnen wenn sie abends ins bett gehen
können sie ruhig schlafen oder haben wir
ein schlechtes gewissen haben sie im
blick dass neben der körperlichen
gesundheit natürlich auch die seelische
gesundheit
eine große rolle spielt und ist die in
gefahr wenn sie so viele west case
szenarien
uns immer wieder vor augen mein ja seine
ganz berechtigte frage man darf nicht
mit worst case szenarien aber das tun
sie ja ja das stimmt nicht also das was
sie malen immer wieder aus wie
dramatisch alles ist dann haben sie auf
ihr aber ist seit twitter twittern sie
jeden tag neue studienjahr aber schlimm
dass wir noch schlimmer aber als ganz
dramatisch nein ist es nicht also es
stimmt einfach schlicht so gar nicht das
kann ich leider nicht stehen lassen so
das verfestigt sich ja das sind also
sagen wir das ist ein wenn ich will
nicht zu nahe treten aber das ist
eigentlich nichts anderes als also was
sie jetzt vorgetragen haben was wir
alles also dramatisch und soweit
sporttage das geschwurbel ich bin
orientieren mich im großen und ganzen an
dem modell des robert-koch-instituts
wenn meier der top-mann und wir fahren
gezielt mit diesem modell schon seit der
zweiten januarwoche fahren wir die
maßnahmen und das hat im großen und
ganzen auch geklappt wir versuchen daher
maßvoll reinzugehen und wenn ich mich
auch wohl eher nicht maßvoll wenn
weltweit wie die strenge maßnahmen haben
wenn um uns herum die maßnahmen fallen
wenn alle auf machen und sie weiter
sagen nein es bleibt so wir haben also
im maßnahmen die im verhältnis zu den
maßnahmen die richtige harte
drakonischen maßnahmen gewesen sind
beispielsweise harte lockdown maßnahmen
haben wir die haben wir selbst in der
ersten welle nicht ergriffen also man
damit sind wir in java weitere jahre
oder weiter erlaubt auch manchmal nicht
mehr über die vergangenheit aber länger
hat ja gesagt die folgeschäden bei
kinder und jugendlichen psychischen
china türlich würde ich es mir wünschen
dass also die bundesländer und es gibt
hier große unterschiede
dass es den bundesländern die für die
schulpolitik zuständig sind zum teil
besser gelingen würde die schulen vor
schweren also infektionswellen die wir
zum tatort beobachten was ja auch die
eltern dann trifft besser zu beschützen
das würde ich mir wünschen nicht länder
unterscheiden sich da zum teil aber ich
will einfach klar noch mal sagen ich bin
nicht zuständig für die schulpolitik das
ist nicht also das kann ich nicht also
darauf habe ich keinen direkten einfluss
was wir machen können dass wir zum
beispiel regeln geben wie lange müssen
kinder in quarantäne das haben wir zum
beispiel für kurz da empfehlen wir im
gegensatz zu erwachsenen fünf tage um
die kinder möglichst schnell wieder in
die schule zu bringen aber man muss auch
offen sein also die also die maßnahmen
die wir ergriffen haben wir jetzt am
wirken sind das sind im wesentlichen
maßnahmen wird die sterblichkeit
reduzieren und wir appellieren an die
länder so viel zu machen damit die
kinder in der schule bleiben können ohne
infektion wie möglich die freibier
zuschauern war ja auch haben sie
eigentlich ein schlechtes gewissen
angesichts dieser folgeschäden die ja
dann auch durch ihre politik entstehen
nämlich dass viele kinder und
jugendliche depressiv werden das ist
große probleme gibt bei menschen die
eben selbstständig sind all diese dinge
diese folgeschäden da hat man in
deutschland auf das gefühl dass sie da
eine politik an den tag legen die sich
eben ausschließlich auf kroner tote
kroner fälle fokussiert nein das ist
natürlich nicht so unser corona politik
und das ja nicht nur meine politik aber
ich stehe für diese politik darum mich
auch heute hier
diese politik hat natürlich wie jeder
andere ärztliche maßnahme nebenwirkungen
und gegners kennt das also wenn sie eine
also gefährliche situation managen wall
für den patienten müssen sie
nebenwirkungen in kauf nehmen wir
versuchen wirklich diese nebenwirkungen
so gering zu halten wie irgend geht dazu
zählt auch zum beispiel dass wir
angebote schaffen für eine also also für
eine zwischen therapeutische betreuung
wir haben also diverse programme am
platz wo sich menschen wenden können
diese niederlage der kinder und
jugendpsychiatrie sind überlastet sie
sagen immer die krankenhäuser sind
überlastet aber real erleben wir dass
man kinder und jugendpsychiater lauf ich
sage es mal so wenn man einräumt dass es
nebenwirkungen gibt dann stimmt das und
das tut mir sehr leid also bin selbst
also vater einer teenager tochter kennen
das ganz genau aber die nebenwirkungen
müssen so gering sein wie geht was ich
nicht gut finde
wo ich ein problem habe ist wenn dann
das leid des einen gegen das leid des
anderen aus spielt das finde ich nicht
gut spaltet die gesellschaft
wir müssen so viel wir können tun um
unsere kinder in der schule zu behalten
ich habe dazu in der vergangenheit immer
wieder vorschläge gemacht auch für die
länder ich habe hier schon gesessen da
habe ich über luft filteranlagen doziert
und gebeten dass er mehr passieren muss
und 2000 aber wir versuchen wirklich die
nebenwirkungen so gering zu halten wie
geht und also das aber ohne nebenwirkung
geht das hier nicht ab das was sie da
ist ich will ihnen einmal zeigen wir
stefan mielchen zu sagen hat auch ein
zuschauer von bild herr lauterbach haben
sie eine idee wie lange der ganze scheiß
noch dauert
das ist eine sehr kurze frage und die
schnelle antwort ist die also ich glaube
nicht dass die letzte variante die
omikron variante ist ich habe mich da
ziemlich tief in die literatur ein
gearbeitet und bin auch mit
wissenschaftlern in kontakt die also
davon leben dass zu analysieren wie
verändern sich das wie verändert sich
das virus und daher wir werden mehr
varianten noch bekommen dafür sie ist
auch noch so viel unterwegs also es gibt
so viel veränderung sehen da selbst die
omikron variante hat sich jetzt
verändert so in einer doch schon relativ
bald in baa2 also in einer relativ
kurzen zeit noch mal deutlich verändert
wir sehen veränderungen bei anderen
varianten das heißt das wird nicht zu
ende sein mit omikron wer meint ja die
maßnahmen da so die maßnahme ich dachte
gesagt hat ich glaube der scheiß war er
bezogen auf masten pflicht zweig zweig
plus all diese dinge die immer noch da
sein und in anderen ländern wechselt er
hat das ist also eher ich gesagt also
die frage also ich bin nicht bereit das
was wir hier tun
um menschenleben zu retten und schwerer
krankheit zu verhindern
und also longo wie zu verhindern und
unsere gesellschaft da so vor schwersten
langfrist folgen zu schützen ich bin
nicht bereit das also also als zu
diskutieren
dennoch haben viele zuschriften uns
erreicht insbesondere in verbindung mit
ihrer person und der frage was für eine
politik in deutschland gemacht wird und
einige zuschauer machen ihnen den
vorwurf dass sie zitat durch angstmache
populär geworden seien und deshalb am
ende gar kein interesse daran hätten
dass die maßnahmen zurückgefahren werden
das ist jetzt eine weitere fragen danach
kommt aber der vorwurf der von vielen
kam und auch bei twitter man ihn immer
wieder liest dass sie durch angstmache
populär geworden seien und deswegen kein
interesse daran hätten dass die
maßnahmen zurückgefahren ja das ist auch
ehrlich gesagt also geschwurbel ich mag
aber kann man wirklich um alles mit
geschwurbel angestellt ist aber diese
zwei dinge also wenn jemand sagt dass
die maßnahmen die wir jetzt ergreifen
mit denen wir so viele menschen
geschützt haben vor schwerster krankheit
und vertont wenn man diese maßnahmen und
abgeformt als scheiß dann ist das aus
jetzt geht es um den vorwurf dass ich
wir haben ja gott dazu habe sie ja sagen
ich hätte alles also als geschwurbel
abgeteilt mir nochmal auf die aussagen
davor reicht da ich bin ein bisschen
bestürzt offen gesagt dass so etwas
überhaupt eingeblendete dabei ist egal
geschenk der bei uns können die
zuschauer ja aber die meinung vertreten
die sie habe aber dann haben sie uns
allen wichtig genau aber dann bekommen
sie auch eine klare vereinbarung bleiben
da bekommen sie eine ganz klare antwort
auch die bleibe ich nicht so legt uns
jetzt hier zum tag also ich arbeite
nicht mit angst sondern ich arbeite
schlicht und ergreifend mit der
darstellung wo wir derzeit sind auf der
grundlage der wissenschaftlichen studien
oder der modelle beispielsweise und das
wird von vielen sogar auch als befreiend
also gesagt geschlagen als verängstigen
empfunden wenn wir zum beispiel also
darauf hinweisen dass also wir mit
impfungen drei mal geimpft eine grund
elysium so erreichen können die vor
weiteren varianten wahrscheinlich so gut
schützt das also wir als gesellschaft
sehr gut geschützt sein werden dass
seine maßnahmen die macht ja nicht angst
sondern sein lösungs schlüssel aber der
andere war das ist für die anderen
politiker wie man zum beispiel markus
söder die jetzt auch sagen wie viele
zuschauer wir müssen jetzt langsam mal
öffnen ist ja ich bleibe trotzdem also
ich bringe ständig lösungen ich habe zum
beispiel dafür gesorgt dass wird packs
logik eines der besten medikamente eine
million dosen gekauft haben also wir
haben impfstoff besorgt die booster
kampagne läuft ich versuche tatsächlich
das ist auch meine aufgabe konkret also
die situation zu bewältigen und die
bewertungen wo wir derzeit stehen nehmen
wir ja im verbund vor robert
koch-institut expertenrat ich selbst da
stehen wir zusammen und das ist eine
beschreiben wo derzeit sind ich nehme
zur kenntnis dass also jetzt im
politischen umfeld also der wunsch nach
lockerungen nicht nur derartigen umfeld
kann ich ihnen sagen herr lauterbach ja
dass ich halte das noch mal hoch was die
forderung von bild ist
ja bei allem respekt vorbild aber also
bild hatakka sie keine
außerparlamentarischen sonderrechte die
hier durchgesetzt werden müssen somit
das nehme ich zur kenntnis das ist aber
mich für mich noch nicht
handlungsleitend da muss mehr kommen als
eine schlagzeile aus dass ich mich
bewegt nicht nur eine schlagzeile
sondern auch eine reaktion darauf die
wir immer wieder hören von unseren
leserinnen und lesern von unseren
zuschauern und die große frage die sich
viele nämlich stellen was muss denn dann
passieren wenn sie dagegen sind bis die
kriterien fall da hat manuel felgen eine
frage zu
und möchte wissen was sind die genauen
kriterien gegeben sein müssen damit alle
maßnahmen und einschränkungen wegfallen
hier ist es eingeblendet können sie
diese kriterien genau formulieren damit
kann man zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch
nicht genau definieren die also es kommt
ja darauf anlegt wie man auch machen
will für einen rückfall prophylaxe das
heißt also was jetzt erst mal für mich
im vordergrund steht dass wir diese
mikrowelle also brechen dass die fahrt
zahlen statt zurückgehen dann können wir
die maßnahmen mit denen wir die
mikrowelle beherrscht haben die können
wir dann zurücknehmen weitestgehend und
dann gehen wir weiter dann muss man auch
schauen was ist insgesamt lage wie hoch
ist die impfquote ich kann immer noch
sagen also der größte
bremser für wirklich maßgebliche und
auch langfristige lockungen sind die
umkämpften wenn es die umkämpften nicht
gäbe dann auch so könnten wir uns was
lockerungen angeht natürlich sehr viel
mehr leisten man darf nicht vergessen
wir schützen hier das gesundheitssystem
vor überforderung und wieso müssen wir
das gesundheitssystem vor überforderung
schützen weil es so viele ungeimpfte
gibt die davon sonst also nicht wie viel
gibt es ja genau können sie uns das
sagen dass ja das problem mit dem
datenkarten und nicht genesen um den
anderen nicht nicht immer sofort chaos
also daten also es gibt unsicherheiten
oder erst einmal unsicherheiten bei den
daten aber so schlimm ist das nicht wir
gehen davon aus dass bei den über
60-jährigen dass die wichtigste gruppe
12 prozent nicht geimpft sind und das
ist eine sehr hohe zahl und das gibt
dann darüber nach hinaus bei denen also
jüngeren auch noch fehle die
risikofaktoren haben die auch ungewiss
sind aber die hauptsorge machen uns
wirklich die zwölf prozent über 60
jährige und das hat england natürlich
eine ganz andere situation ich bin eben
sie haben ja auch angesprochen also
england lockert jetzt und also gehen
sehr viel weiter na ja da geht man davon
aus dass bei den über 60-jährigen nur
zwei prozent nicht geimpft sind oder
genesen aber bei uns kann man das ja
nicht mal sagen das ist ja das große
problem wieso kann man das nicht sagen
weil die daten die wir haben am ende
nicht vergleichbar sind mit denen in
england naja ich da wäre ich auch
vorsichtig also es gibt ja die daten des
robert koch institut ist die also
ausweisen wie viele impfungen sind
gemacht worden und die entsprechend
ungefähr dem auf was in der praxis dann
sehen ich will ihnen einmal zeigen was
michael na wollt wissen will der sagt
nämlich warum lassen wir es mit omikron
nicht einfach laufen andere länder tun
es doch auch in die krankenhäuser kommen
doch deswegen nicht mehr menschen als
bei anderen krankheiten ich kenne auch
fälle wo ungeimpfte keine symptome
hatten also dass man wegen denen nicht
lockert ist für nicht nachvollziehbar ja
es entspricht eben nicht im
wissenschaftlichen sachstand das ist zum
beispiel nicht die position unseres
expertenrats also die diese strategie
wenn man das an der stadt laufen lassen
eine strategie zu nennen ist ein
bisschen bemüht aber sagen wir lassen
das jetzt durch gehen und sagen das ist
eine strategie wir lassen es einfach
laufen das lehnt der expertenrat ab das
leben die wissenschaftler abdi und sonst
beraten das wird uns aus dem ausland
auch nicht geraten bei der hohen als
sozial der ungewiss sind ich konnte das
selbst auch nicht vertreten oder wieder
als minister noch so als wissenschaftler
weil wir hätten dann innerhalb von
kurzer zeit hätten wir halt schwer
schwere fälle das ist einfach so wir
sehen dass zum beispiel in frankreich
das da gibt es auch noch ungenügend noch
nicht bis in alle ewigkeit audi werde
die wir sind jetzt überlegen ja dieser
panne während sich jetzt immer noch in
die welle wird ja jetzt gebrochen ich
habe ja schon also in der zweiten
januarwoche habe ich gesagt dass wir den
höhepunkt mitte februar mit der
mikrowelle erwarten können das kann sich
also noch ein bisschen hinziehen wegen
ba2 das glaube ich aber nicht aber wir
sind wirklich vor dem höhepunkt der
welle dann gehen die fallzahlen deutlich
runter und dann kann man auch sehr gut
locker und vornehmen also das ist jetzt
wir sind jetzt quasi im dritten jahr der
panne auf dem haben noch nicht so
fahrzeugen gehabt und also in das
maximum der fallzahlen hinein jetzt zu
lockern das bedeutet hat ich glaube öl
ins feuer dann bleiben wir bei der frage
der lockerungen das ist das was die
menschen momentan mit am meisten bewegt
csu-chef söder noch einmal hat gesagt
wir brauchen konsequente öffnung
schritte in ein zwei wochen fdp-chef
lindner fordert bundesweite abschaffung
aller zweig regeln für den handel nach
dem vorbild von schleswig-holstein und
eine strategie für öffnung schritte ja
das werden wir alles am 16 diskutieren
was ist da ihre position ich will hier
der also diskussion sie werden der
gruppe haben nicht vorweg greifen
das wird sich nicht gehören also ich
glaube dass wir tatsächlich diese
debatte haben werden sind sie für
lockerungen oder dagegen das kommt da
waren wir die paar zahlen sich jetzt
entwickeln jetzt im moment bin ich
dagegen das habe ich ja auch also heute
noch mal in ihrem blatt klar gesagt weil
ich halte es für verrückt wenn man bei
höchstzahlen also von infizierten und
einer guten strategie die funktioniert
wir haben also wie deutlich weniger
sterbefälle als andere länder weil die
also die abschottung der eltern und
risikofaktoren funktioniert wieso soll
ich bei höchstzahlen von infizierten an
einer funktionierenden strategie dann
lockern die frage ist ja ob diese
strategie funktioniert wir haben über
folgeschäden schon gesprochen und über
das was das mit deutschland macht was es
mit den kindern und jugendlichen macht
was ist mit unserem land macht dass wir
einfach weiter so machen wie vorher dass
die anderen um uns herum öffnen und wir
weiterhin bei diesem strikten kurs
bleiben sie können sagen sie
konzentrieren sich allein darauf was ist
für tote was es für fälle bei krone
bedeutet aber die gesamtlage ist ja
völlig undurchschaubar nächsten show
durchschaubar wir haben ja
rettungspakete am platz also und wir
flankieren ja das was wir derzeit machen
mit erheblichen wirtschaftspolitischen
maßnahmen sie müssen einräumen dass wir
im vergleich zu anderen ländern die es
lockerer genommen haben gut auch
wirtschaftlich durch die krise bisher
gekommen sind also aber die begründung
für die maßnahme war ja immer dass eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystem
verhindert werden muss und wenn man sich
das anschaut gibt es jetzt noch die
gefahr dass intensivstation volllaufen
und kollabieren und wie wahrscheinlich
ist das warum ist das in der mikrowelle
dann in keinem anderen land passiert und
sie waren weiter davor wir haben halt im
vergleich zu anderen ländern haben wir
hat die hohe zahl ungeimpfte älterer
menschen das ist ganz einfach so also
wenn ich das jetzt so laufen lassen dann
so werden dann
explodieren die fallzahlen und dann sind
sie halt betroffen der älteren menschen
und ebenso gehen davon aus dass immer
noch eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystem droht das zeigen die
modelle ganz klar also wenn wir es jetzt
laut werden wir das jetzt komplett
öffnen würden ja und also es ist ein
unterschied ob ich jetzt hier etwas
schätze oder uns war das wort sondern
die modelle die bisher die letzten
wochen sehr gut vorhergesagt haben
welche quellen er hat darum gebeten dass
die auch also bei
also auf der homepage des robert koch
instituts veröffentlicht werden eben
dieses modell bernd meyer der borgmann
das ein modell wenn arbeiten auch mit
einem anderen modell noch von viola
prise man aber das modell von meyer und
braucht man das heißt relativ gut
vorhergesagt was auf den also an den
fahrzeugen zu sehen ist und also an den
auf den intensivstationen und das gibt
dem keinen grund zur entwarnung und
daher hat der experten hat das auch
nicht empfohlen